ben sur Dijon François est largement en
tête donc dans un contexte national très
difficile parce qu'au niveau national ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que c'est une
défaite on va pas dire le contraire
pourquoi parce que d'abord il y a le
phénomène de l'abstention sanction c'est
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche qui ne
sont pas allés voter alors qui on envoyé
un message c'est vrai par l'abstention
en même temps à Dijon il y a un score
important de franç il est largement en
tête donc il y a une dynamique
enclenchée dès le premier tour on va
dire que nous avons marqué un essai
maintenant il faut le trans et donc dès
demain il faudra continuer cette
mobilisation je constate aussi quand
même que à Dijon l'UMP fait un très
faible score l'UMP udi que le Front
national effectivement a fait un score
important ser 12 vous confirmez on n pas
encore les résultats défini 1 donc on on
va voir avec le dépouillement et donc
voilà la situation et donc la situation
c'est bien sûr la mobilisation pour le
second tour sur la base du programme sur
la base de nos propositions sur la base
d'une équipe qui est soudée ce qui était
pas le cas de l'UMP notamment et du
candidat de l'UMP et donc nous allons
continuer le travail après en Côte d'Or
c'est vrai il y a de nombreuses communes
qui ont basculé et donc c'est un fait à
prendre r compte et je pense aussi bien
aux socialistes qui se sont battus dans
de nombreuses communes qui ce soir ont
perdu comment comment faudra-t-il le
prendre en compte mais écoutez le
prendre en
compteaniment ça je ne sais pas nous
verrons cela en tout cas pour l'instant
il faut en prendre acte il va falloir
travailler d'arrachepied le contexte est
difficile on le sait un contexte
difficile avec un chômage important
avec des résultats qui se font attendre
et donc il faut continuer le travail
l'amplifier et c'est pas simple